I'm an introvert not amazing
academically didn't feel like it
belonged anywhere average at best and
yeah you created Spotify yeah
Daniel Peck Spotify founder ncuo he's
not only saved the music industry he's
created a 50 billion dollar company and
he himself is worth more than four
billion dollars flunked high school then
started on my first company and that
later got Acquired and you retired at
23. yeah the first month was fun
nightclub sports car 20 or 30 girls
throwing around money six months in
realized that this thing I thought I
wanted I just didn't want at all I was
just empty just thinking am I ever gonna
get out of this depression and what to
do in life what if you can work on
something you actually care about what
would you pick music but the industry's
going down the drain I honestly did not
think we would succeed but if we succeed
I knew it was going to be a big thing
Spotify is here a One-Stop shop for
music Spotify I love it I read the
journey to that success I had multiple
near-death experiences it was awful ran
out of money I lost all of the air
gained 30 pounds and the problem was I
modeled myself from The Mark zuckerbergs
of the world around every meeting I did
the best product person and it just
wasn't me share the burden with someone
it is so important we tend to believe
the world is more logical than what it
is but it's based on relationships be
easiest person to deal with and you'd be
surprised how many problems it solves
one of those problems was Apple
what's your opinion on Apple
[Music]
Daniel what is the most important
context that I need to know about you to
understand the man that sits in front of
me today and when I ask about context I
want to go right back to where you come
from and that earliest environment that
I almost I'll miss it like an oven I see
at our earliest context as like an oven
that baked us into who we are today what
is that context
I'm a product of a very very strong
single mom
a woman that probably had a ship on her
shoulder
um
um against her sibling her brother her
older brother who kind of said you can't
do this you can't race
a child to be productive
um and I think she kind of uh just well
hell-bent on making a point of showing
that you know
um I was going to be successful in her
definition and successful meant
well-educated well-read and be able to
handle almost anything thrown at me and
just to give you an example of that
while I was brought up in the suburb of
Stockholm very much a working class
rough neighborhood one of the big things
that my mother did was
she had me
um doing a pentathlon and the pentathon
was like the classic pentathlon so that
means fencing horseback riding shooting
running and swimming doesn't sound like
what someone basically from the projects
in in Stockholm would do but she thought
that would be a good sort of
wide education for me
um and and pretty much my entire life
has been around that I I was kind of
clumsy as a kid
um my my fine motor skills was pretty
good my rough motor skills wasn't very
good so she enrolled me in like an
all-female gymnastics group
you know I'm an introvert so she
enrolled me in a theater group to have
me you know learn how to express myself
uh and and so
um an Eclectic childhood but one where
she heavily influenced me
brought me along in almost every context
with adults with professors like at a
very early age and just had me sit along
or with just the person from next door
who's struggling uh getting to the next
paycheck and and I really saw all of
those contracts in life from a very
young age
did she have any desire for you to
become any specific thing because uh I I
I'm honestly not sure but I think she
wanted me to be broad
um just in general
um so
um and and I I think in many families
you kind of have this maybe educational
pressure where you have to be a doctor
you have to be a lawyer like none of
that mattered to my mom
um the only thing that mattered and she
kept repeating us was that you need to
become a good human being
um and for her
um if I wanted to study sure she thought
education mattered and it was important
but
um not like in other families and the
only thing in fact
um you know probably influenced Spotify
later on was
um I very much come from a music family
my my grandfather was an opera singer my
grandmother was an actress in theater
but also a jazz pianist so
um like music education was weirdly
enough like in the the premier education
that was focused on for me and then all
the other stuff she was basically only
important that I showed effort
um I I had a pretty easy time in school
and so she constantly kept pushing me
because she felt that I wasn't I wasn't
making enough of an effort uh no matter
what so it wasn't about the grade I
could come home with a straight A uh she
would still be like well did you really
make an effort I don't think so and um
and um and and so for her it was kind of
always that thing about like just
pushing and making the real effort
so she cared more about less about the
outcome and more about how much of your
potential you were realizing yeah
very much so
so on school then you you reference that
she kind of identified you're an
introvert early on but then I think you
said you had a good you're an easy time
in school typically people that are
introverted that are
um an only child at the time that they
go off to school
often they struggle a little bit yeah
because you know finding friends and
fitting into social groups and I read
somewhere else that you don't love small
talk you tend to gravitate towards the
people that you know yeah what was
school like for someone for a kid like
that
well I I think you know
um I think there are many types of
introverts let's begin with that and I
can switch it on when I have to uh and
certainly I think the theater helped me
um you know I can be very project a lot
of things if I'd like to uh and be a
force of nature but it doesn't come easy
that requires tons of energy whereas
others get energy from like the room and
they're like very excited it's just not
me
um for me anything with anyone I'm not
comfortable with is really taking a lot
of energy
um
um but but I think the easy time in
school was just uh I loved learning I've
always loved learning so
um you know you put be putting in an
environment where you're constantly
being forced to learn new things wasn't
a very hard thing for me and um I have a
very good
um I used to have a very good memory I
don't have it anymore but I was able to
memorize very easily the concepts and
the things that we talked about in
school
and so
um I think in that end it was very easy
for me and then again because my mother
tried to make me very broad
um the positive and the negative of that
aspect is I could kind of be in any
social group I could be with the
athletes I wasn't the best athlete by
any stretch of the imagination
but it worked I could be in the
musicians group as well with any of the
people really good at Arts uh man I did
you know I probably wasn't the best at
any of that stuff either but it was
pretty decent but I could also be in the
math group I probably wasn't the best of
math but I was pretty decent and
um that to be honest is kind of the
Story of My Life
um you can kind of plug me in anywhere I
won't excel at practically anything
but I'll hold my fort
and that's I think both a blessing and a
curse the blessing is in is that it's
very easy for people to
for me to be able to relate to other
people enough where I'm accepted in the
group
but it's hard in the sense the downside
with that is that I never really belong
anywhere because I'm not that one-sided
as an individual you know I'm not an
artist I'm not a technologist
I'm not a business person I'm all of
that and probably a few other things as
well
and and you can see that very clearly
with my friend group too you'll have
artists on the one set and you have
entrepreneurs on the other hand and it's
very hard for them to speak to each
other most times but I love it I love
um seeing very creative people I love uh
you know business people and scientists
mixed together whereas the scientist
gets very you know
have a hard time I've found uh speaking
to and an artist and quite often they're
talking past each other and for me it's
just I love it
um and and that's the blessing and curse
when I speak to people that know you and
work with you they describe you as
ambitious
now ambition and being ambitious is an
interesting word because it's often
loaded with this presumption that
someone has a desire for a certain
outcome yeah like they're trying to
they're ambitious because they want to
be really successful or they want
gazillion pounds
um are you ambitious and what does that
actually mean to you
um yeah I'm I'm ambitious
um but I probably am ambitious in the uh
the way my mother taught me to be
ambitious which is the inputs right
which is
um you know if I see someone with
Incredible potential that squanders that
potential
um I
um I asked myself why why are you doing
this and why not strive for the great
thing and in so many cases in life I
found that the difference between you
know aiming super high versus
um aiming just a little bit higher than
where you are from an effort perspective
it's about the same effort so you might
just as well aim higher you know this
saying of you shoot for the stars and
you land on the Moon that is very much
kind of my life philosophy why not try
to do it bigger why not try to do it um
even more interesting and maybe you have
to settle for something less
but isn't it more interesting and more
fun to try to do the really big hairy
Bodacious thing not for everyone
maybe maybe not uh but I don't know that
because you'll work with so many people
that maybe
don't lean into ambition
yeah that that's true but I I also
wonder if if that's true uh or whether
they're just worried about
really testing themselves and
understanding where their limits are so
many people are more afraid of failure
than they are of success uh and that
stops them from even beginning to try
um right and and I find that so many
times like the amount of people I'm sure
came to you is like oh it's really good
for you but I had the same idea it's
like okay well why didn't you do
anything about it
and and oftentimes it's like well for
this and that and that reason and and
they talk themselves out of it um but at
the very core I believe it comes down to
that they're actually more worried about
failing than they are about the
prospects of succeeding
your kids then what would you advise
them to do if they were say they wanted
to follow in your Footsteps in
particular or start a business at that
juncture where we kind of leave High
School yeah and we can either go into
like work or university would you do you
think the the university system is a
little bit outdated yeah I do
um but as with many things
um you know I I I don't think it's bad I
don't think it's good either I think it
depends there are certain people that do
well in that structure and and need that
kind of rigor of that sort of path to go
down and do incredibly well
um against
um you know the essays and the Asics and
they're really good and they're really
good with the lectures and then taking
the notes and just have that sort of
discipline in that area of their life
where they do well in that circumstance
and then that education then sets them
up for a greater things so I think it
depends I mean if your dream is to
become a lawyer then I think you have to
go through path right
um because it's impossible otherwise I
think if you want to be an entrepreneur
uh the single best thing you can do is
to probably study as many businesses you
can and get as much business exposure in
that so what do I mean by that well it
can come in by working for businesses
that are great but more importantly
probably working for great individuals
and learning from them right so if you
are fortunate enough to be able to do
um you know we're talking about this but
you're behind the scenes version
um
and and and being able to like work for
you in that and see you up up close it's
going to be invaluable for that
individual to get to do that because you
get to see entrepreneurship from the
first row you get to see what it's like
um of what business aspect what um you
know how do you do that how much admin
do you need to carry and even if you're
just a fly on the wall You're Gonna
Learn so many skills that are quite
diverse and and that's the I think the
biggest trick about entrepreneurship is
like the the for me
uh everyone when they think about the
word Innovation they think that it's
something entirely novel yet for me
Innovation
um I don't know of a single thing that
just someone came up with that had no
prior grounds everything is about
putting two or more things in together
in a new context
so studying many different things
understanding a little bit about
business understanding a little bit
about
um product and how to make that product
understanding uh whatever it is that our
drivers from that I think is important
and that's not to say that University
can't do that and it can't be helpful to
learning sales and the theory of it Etc
but I think that there is many other
paths you could take that may even if
you're
um you know if you have enough grits and
kind of like are able to put yourself in
a situation where you can get in front
of the right person start working for
them so much is in life is around people
believing in you and and giving you the
right place to grow
um and and and it's really serendipitous
to be honest
um and and I'm certainly a product of
all that so I I think it is not right or
wrong it's just I dislike how we're
talking about it as it is the way or
um you know it's not the way and it's
like no I think it's more like it works
sometimes for certain individuals and
then for other individuals it is not the
best use of their time and there are
other paths you can take but educating
yourself even if that's outside of a
university and getting a degree concept
that I think is invaluable and it's the
most important thing you can be doing as
a young individual about anything you're
interested in
I think that's one of the big
misconceptions people have about me when
they hear I dropped out of University
they think I don't like education yeah
no no no no no yeah I spend all day like
all night till 2am learning about
rockets and Ai and all that stuff I'm a
self-educated but the institution of
Education that is University for me I
just couldn't stay awake yeah in that
experience same here but for another
person it is exactly what they they need
because they may not even know what
they're interested in and they feel like
I want to have a foundation that gives
me a broad base so again if a Masters of
Science degree if if you know you want
to be an engineer but you're not
entirely sure
what type of engineer it's a very broad
Foundation that will teach you Elemental
skills that you probably will use at
some point in time I'm not saying you
can't go outside of that realm too but
it's great stuff
um and if you're wired that way you do
well in that type of environment great
and there's certain types of people that
do that
when young
people come up to me and ask me this
question about what I should be doing
with my life at that early stage the
advice I've started to give and I want
to check how you how you would change or
add alter this advice is to try and go
and join us startup so just for context
I'm talking about people that want to be
entrepreneurs here yeah to try and go
and join a startup that's doing
something at the very Cutting Edge
of the world or a wave that's currently
coming into Shore so I would say the
young kids like go and join an AI
startup and the reason I say startup is
because you're going to be closer to the
decision making you're going to learn
more you can have more exposure than
like if you went and worked I know at
Google or something sure
um and also it's the cheapest way to
fail when you're young right like you
can observe the company fall into the
graveyard yeah without there being a
huge cost to you yeah
I I would agree I mean I I think that is
a tremendous
um
uh opportunity uh to do that
um but again I've seen other paths work
too I've seen people uh join bigger
companies and move around inside of that
company and
um get a super valuable skills
um and then eventually
um kind of break out as an entrepreneur
as well and maybe you wanted to save up
some money and obviously if you're doing
a little bit of a bigger company you're
able to do that and prioritize doing
both and then you know once you have
that kind of Nest Egg of sorts you can
then break out and so I I don't know I
it's like the I used to think
um and you and I we were talking about
this before I used to think that you
know hey I've got all this advice I'm
gonna just gonna give it and the more
and more I on a personal basis I'm not
sure I'm in a great position to give
advice on many things
um and and so I I try to stay away from
it I can't help myself when I feel like
people are doing it but I try to not do
it as much as I do
um it is actually something I'm deeply
conscious about because I don't think
that there's one path in life I think
that there are many paths in life
and of course there are really bad ones
um but but
some some of the more amazing life
stories aren't the obvious ones uh it is
not the people even doing the sort of
hey I joined the startup or I did this
and that it may be the person who spent
um started like life in a lab to only
get so frustrated in the end that they
end up
breaking out and then forming a company
because no one else wanted to do the
idea that they had in mind or maybe the
person who uh was the least likely to
solve that problem but had really been
spending all this time thinking about it
and developed this really odd skill
while doing their normal day job that
then turn out to be really useful to
solving this particular problem
I find it incredibly fascinating that
when we look at the back end of spotify
and apple and our audio channels the
majority of people that watch this
podcast haven't yet hit the follow
button or the Subscribe button wherever
you're listening to this I would like to
make a deal with you if you could do me
a huge favor and hit that subscribe
button I will work tirelessly from now
until forever to make the show better
and better and better and better I can't
tell you how much it helps when you hit
that subscribe button the show gets
bigger which means we can expand the
production bring in all the guests you
want to see and continue to doing this
thing we love if you could do me that
small favor and hit the follow button
wherever you're listening to this that
would mean the world to me that is the
only favor I will ever ask you thank you
so much for your time back to this
episode and going back to that first
company that was acquired at vertigo
after that was acquired um I read that
you retired at 23. yeah I'm guessing
that made you
enough money to retire yep and you're 23
which is in 2006 and you're a retired
man living what one can only describe as
any 23 year old's dream yeah lots of
money guessing there was some champagne
there I think there was a red Ferrari
how was that for you
it was amazing no no all jokes aside I
grew up and as I said I was kind of like
always socially accepted but didn't feel
like it belonged anywhere and um
hi
um
um I never had an easy time with girls
um not a bad time just not as as good as
if I was widely successful in music or
widely successful in sports or any of
that stuff and I kind of had odd
interests because I kept as I said kind
of moving from group to group
um and so I had this idea in my head
um that I wanted to you know be
financially independent
um I wanted I thought that once I got to
that point I would start living life and
I thought that
um you know
I would be more socially accepted and I
would find my tribe and it's
embarrassing to talk about it now
um but
um you know that was really what I
thought so I thought that if I was lucky
and worked really hard I might be able
to retire in my 40s
if I work really hard but you know 50s
for sure and and
um so you know getting to that point
when I was 22 actually not 23 it was
just mind-boggling to me and
um I had that Financial Target in mind
um and I thought well once I hit that
I'm just gonna like you know do
something else and and so as you said I
kind of like started frequenting all the
night clubs uh bought a sports car
um try to get the girls I could never
get before
realizing that yes I could get them
um but for all the wrong reasons and
they didn't really care about me
um and it was kind of a hollowing thing
because it was this kind of oh was this
what I worked for for such a long period
of time and then
um only to find out that
um you know it was quite depressing
honestly I had all these new friends
that weren't really great friends at all
um luckily I was able to keep my old
friends as well but I realized that this
thing I thought I wanted uh I just
didn't want at all and um what was the
symptom
when we say realize there's typically
symptoms psychological symptoms or
um no I I realized that because I I'm
um you know I started getting all these
phone calls from people
um asking me to come out on Friday
evening since Saturday evenings
uh and I just I was just empty I just
had no energy to do that
um and I thought to myself oh this is
odd because the old me thought this was
what life was all about and I had had
girls call me and like hey you should
really come out we miss you all of that
stuff and I realized that I just didn't
care and had um I thought that that was
you know this magical moment and in fact
um you know putting on my computer or
playing my guitar
was kind of yeah this is more me and so
something on the back of my head started
forming around like who am I why do I
care about it and it's it's actually in
that process I met my co-founder because
he was the founder of trade doubler
and uh who uh bought my uh company and
he too it kind of the company had ipo'd
he got kicked out of the company he he
was like a 100 times more wealthier than
I was like he he had like the biggest
success in Tech Sweden at the time and
had everything going for him but he
didn't know what to do with life and so
that was kind of how we bonded
um and um you know we were watching like
old Godfather movies eating crisps
um and and talking about what to do in
life uh and and that was like a real
friendship moment a real Turning Point
uh and he saw
um the same thing that I saw and uh
um you know that was when I realized
that I've been approaching this all
wrong uh in fact I always loved working
it was never about money
um I always liked learning
um and I would pay to go learn for
someone rather than getting paid for it
and but at the same time I thought work
should be hard that was the thing that I
had programmed into me so work has to be
clearly something you not don't enjoy
doing
um so I thought well what if you change
all of these parameters what if you
create an environment where you can come
in and learn from really smart people
all the time what if you can work on
something you actually care about
opposed to something that makes money
what if you could have a lot of fun
while doing it and not take it too
serious
and we started talking and we were
balancing ideas and marked and my
co-founder was like asking me like Well
if you really could pick anything like
what what would you pick and I I'm I
said some well
um you know I'd probably pick music but
that's a terrible idea uh and he said
well why is that a terrible idea and I
said well it's a terrible idea because
you know the industry's going down the
drains it just doesn't work it's piracy
it's all of these reasons and he said
okay but but if one would fix it how
would one do well it can kind of stupid
they're trying to regulate it
clearly you need to build a better
product that's the only thing that's
going to work is they said okay well how
are you going to do that and it's like
well I don't know but maybe you could do
this or that okay well how would that
work uh it's like well I don't know but
maybe you could do this and that and how
would you make money well I I think
maybe you could pay out based on how
much people were listening I don't know
and then literally after going through
why not uh 100 times I started realizing
that yeah why not and why not give this
a shot and I told him from the beginning
you know uh that um hey this is probably
gonna lose us a lot of money I have a
hard time seeing this ever being a
sustainable business
um
but I'm in let's do this and it's a
great let's do it
um and while I was hesitating for some
reason he wasn't uh so he was like this
seems fun let's do it and that gave me
enough confidence where I kind of had
found a new purpose again and instantly
I stopped responding to all the people
who were trying to get me out in the
evenings and I was like well I got
something to do and then I went back to
work again and it was like
pretty much a week from that moment
where I felt like I'm happy again I
haven't felt this happy for
you know the better part of a year
because it was about a year when I was
going through this transition of of just
having fun being retired
um first month was fun six months in
depressing uh nine months in am I ever
gonna get out of this depression to then
count of a year in finding something
else that I truly look forward to that
felt crazy
um and I honestly did not think we would
succeed but if we succeed I knew it was
going to be a big thing
something really interesting there that
I could relate to a lot was this idea
that you had a hypothesis about your
happiness that had to fail you
to know that it was not a valid
hypothesis about happiness and there's
so many people obviously I mean there's
I assume it's more than half the
population are currently pursuing a
hypothesis they have about what will
make them happy that probably and this
is the thing I always wonder is does it
have to fail them for them to know that
that's not the right pursuit in my case
it did had to fail me yeah I had to feel
the anti-climax and then I had to go and
buy the big house and then was there for
nine months and got out of it as quick
as I could and bought the car and then
got rid of the car and then just moved
as close to the office as I could in a
one bedroom studio apartment yeah yeah
but for a lot of people I'm like is
there a way for them not for it for them
not to have to go all that way and have
it fail them well I I think that there's
certain life experiences
um uh that you can't learn from other
people you just have to live live it and
I think it's not so much about sort of
the monetary thing or the status thing
um although I would probably say status
whether or not you should really seek it
I think is one of those things that we
all have to go through I think everyone
can talk about it don't seek attention
don't seek Fame don't seek all of these
things but we're we're human beings we
want to be well liked by other people
um and so I think that is probably one
of them but but in general I think the
further away it is from anything you
know and can relate to I think
um
we have to experience parts of it so you
know one one of the most amazing thing
that I get to do these days for my
friends is
um from like back when is I take them on
these crazy experiences uh right you
know I'm I'm fortunate enough that I get
to see some of the coolest people in the
world whether it's musicians but
athletes and and so on
um that they're able to get a glimpse of
my life uh and I love it because
um you know they're looking at it with
this kind of child shy like imagination
and wonder about some some things that
I'm going through but I also see the
other side when they're like isn't
really that much work wow I would never
want to do this and it's it's quite
helpful
um because as we started out saying they
have this idea of what the life is so I
kind of like bringing them along on the
journey where they get to see it and
then
um you can see that there are aspects of
it that they like and then other aspects
that they would never ever want to get
into
um so
um you know I think it might be possible
to kind of simulate that experience
um but I think you have to experience
it's very much up close uh certainly
when you're talking about wealth and if
you come from having none I think almost
everyone then would instantly need to
experience a little bit of it to at
least kind of understand whether that's
important or not especially if you get
it like we both did probably in our 20s
and so on had a had I worked up until my
40s I may have kind of realized hey this
isn't life I'm I'm having children I'm
having my wife this is amazing I got
this experience being a single guy
trying to chase girls and and all I'd
seen was on MTV how all of the rappers
were throwing around money and uh having
20 or 30 girls at the nightclub and and
you know hey I wanted that too
one thing I'm really interested in is
you said you got to nine months and you
were depressed nine months after the
sale there are so many people now and
this is why I asked about what the
symptoms of that were it's hard to know
yeah when we're drifting down the wrong
path because it creeps up on us like a
frog and a frying pan yeah I I remember
a time working seven days a week and
this feeling in my chest if I would
describe it as like a
a subtle growing emptiness
and that was for me in hindsight I was
lonely yep and I didn't know I was yeah
so those symptoms that you encountered
at nine months in
in a way that someone might relate to
them what were those feelings
um I I think my entire life as I
mentioned I I've been struggling to fit
in
um
and I think it's something we probably
share and have in common and I somehow
thought that this would help and
um when the situation was new
um it did feel like I found my new tribe
and it did feel like they
um
um you know this early excitement
everyone's calling you everyone wants
you to be part of something that you're
before may not have been able to enjoy
and may not go get those phone calls and
get made out of get into the hottest
nightclubs in in the club promoters like
putting you on the list plus 10 and all
that stuff this social currency so it
was thrilling it was absolutely amazing
and and it truly was this kind of like
wow I've made it kind of feeling
um but
um after you experience the tenth time
and I somehow had this idea that it
would translate into this continuous
feeling of that thing or translate into
something more meaningful I I sort of
realized that no wait a minute it's the
same experience again but it's lost a
little bit of a charm and I started now
getting the hangarounds that we're
trying to get in with me because you
know they realized that maybe I would
buy the bottles
um I was seeing people at the table come
up and grab a glass and then run away
all of that kind of thing and I I it's
slowly sort of dawned upon me that you
could replace me by just anyone else
that had
um the money and the connection that I
had at that time thereby the status and
it really would matter
um you know and and
um
uh you know I I was I was listening to I
think it's his name is Morgan household
um the author who talks about psychology
of money and he kind of talked about it
the the the Ferrari syndrome and he
basically describes that uh everyone uh
who aspires to buy a Ferrari
um thinks of themselves and saying oh
well one day when I'm in this Ferrari
everyone's gonna look at this Ferrari
and they're gonna be amazed with me yet
what we all do is we look at the Ferrari
and we want to sit there we actually
don't care about the individual that's
currently sitting in there so this kind
of
um you know Paradox
um so to speak and and that's very much
how I felt about my life and as you're
right right it you push that to the side
and you say well surely this you know
this is fun and you have all these other
people coming out and then you kind of
bury it and then it keeps coming up and
then it comes up again and then it comes
up more and more and more and I didn't
realize what it was at first because I
was like surely I'm just being foolish
this is this is life and everyone was
rewarding me on the outside too saying
what in life you live this is amazing
how cool is not to be retired and just
not having to do anything
um
but I wasn't learning and I wasn't
forming genuine connections with people
um I was just being and uh yes I got
status but I realized I never did
anything for status and I actually
didn't care in the end uh from being
status I cared about belonging but not
in that group
I wanted to be in another group that
cared about me for being me
and you must have learned a lot now in
hindsight about what the core components
of you being sufficiently happy are
you've used a few of them there like
learning was one of them belonging
what are the other core components of
you think for someone just it's easier
to just talk about ourselves here yeah
for you to be stable
um I I realized
um
that I also need to be live by be
allowed to be by myself
right
um so I used to in Prior relationships
um before meeting my wife I used to
think you know your relationship you
constantly need to do something with the
other party and it was draining me
and uh I used to think there was
something wrong with me because I wanted
to be by myself for most of the time
and
um and being comfortable with that I am
that way that I thrive on loneliness not
all the time because I can feel lonely
um but
um for quite a lot of time perhaps more
so than most normal people like being
lonely
um I'm I'm just finding myself in that
um place where I just pursue whatever
um it's top of mind for me I am sort of
in my own thoughts uh wandering dreaming
scheming
um you know
um that's been very important too
because I used to think there was
something wrong with that yeah and then
my wife luckily she's kind of the same
she does her thing and I do mind thing
and we love that we can do stuff with
each other but we're also perfectly
happy doing things on our own
um and um and that kind of taught me
also quite a lot about myself
in that because again we are social
animals uh and I am too by the way I
love
um hanging out with my friends but I
also love being by myself so I think
having a positive impact
um not just on myself I have to feel
good about what I'm doing and know that
it helps someone
um being able to learn uh being able to
have fun while doing it and
um then be in an environment where I can
be lonely and then can come back without
that being sort of socially awkward uh
like one of my favorite things that I
can do with my close friends
is I can literally uh let's say I would
host a dinner I could host the dinner
and I get an idea it's very uncommon but
I'll get an idea and I will walk away
and disappear for an hour and I'll come
back
um and uh that's like something that's
kind of socially unacceptable in most
situations I do realize that so I I try
to not do that if I'm I'm with um you
know strangers because they wouldn't
understand they wouldn't won't
understand but my real friends
um they know that about me and they're
like totally cool so they just hang out
and then when I come back I love that
they're there and I love that they're
hanging out with my kids or hanging out
with my wife and doing other stuff and
just being comfortable in in that that
for me is like a perfect dinner is one
where I would be social I would get an
idea walk away
think about it for a moment get collect
my thoughts get energy write it down and
come back
filled with energy from that and then
you know continue the conversation uh
that's a great example of something I
love doing so that's actually happened
where you've been at a dinner party with
friends and then you've had an idea and
you've left you've and then you've my
thing there is if I left so the first
thing is I'm not sure my girlfriend
would be very happy yeah she understands
that I'm like that she understands that
I love being alone she understands that
I get ideas at predictable times and
that idea might suck me away she
probably wouldn't be that happy
um about it probably need to have a
conversation about that
um but also if I went away I would need
to start working on the idea because I'd
get so energized about the thing
that I then spend all night like sorry
guys I yeah
that happens by the way it happens that
I like finished halfway through the
dinner and just disappear don't come
back to I would say my friends usually
uh even my close friends are like uh hey
we came to hang out with you not like to
see you for half an hour and then you're
disappearing but it happens
um
um but I can obviously equally be there
for all the dinner too
um and and yeah I mean it is one of the
social Oddities I think that I do
um with my close friends
um and I again I I know it's highly
socially unacceptable in most situations
but but if you really think about it as
an introvert as I said I usually thrive
on I need social elements but I get most
of my energy being by myself all right
and and so then from an energy balance
uh perspective being with people it
gives me a lot of ideas it's great but
it also empties my energy Reserve then
going away filling them up again coming
back it is probably the ideal way for me
if you ask me like what would a perfect
night look like it would probably be
that
how do you then balance
romance and relationships and my partner
her I think her attachment style in her
love language is like quality time
so I often violate that love language
because of what you've just described
yeah we could be Saturday in a park and
then I think about something or get an
email and then I'm off away on my own
little world yeah
yeah I mean that's certainly the risk
um again I'm I'm fortunate enough that
my wife was kind of very similar to me
in that regard so she too leaves uh
dinners and has her ideas and and uh you
know do that so I think we're we're more
similar we try to make sure that one of
us stay because it gets very awkward
otherwise
um but but if you're both like that do
you have to have rules though for when
you do yeah yeah well that's the thing
that's that's actually the harder thing
for us is finding that quality time so I
mean there's two parts you can either
have I I like the faults so you can have
like the default this we spend time
together or the default is we're in a
relationship but we don't spend time
together and so you have to make time
where you're actively finding something
you both are interested in and you want
to spend time on together
and I think we're more that and I think
most people probably with kids would
recognize that because the kids come
first in the relationship anyway so your
relationship to your significant other
um is probably you know uh the second
priority in that relationship and in
your wants to kids uh are the first so I
don't think that's uncommon but I think
changing that default could be really
important
um and again if it's something that's
really important to my wife of course
I'm going to be present uh she's really
into horse riding I'm not but I know it
matters to her greatly so not only will
I try to speak to her every morning when
she wants to talk about that but I also
show up for her competitions or I show
up for important practices that she has
as well and
um there are aspects of the horsing
thing where we can Bond and and have
great quality time as well as it is she
loves hearing about my entire Muriel and
diverse as well and and we find quality
time through that and then we have date
nights like post couples do and uh yeah
I mean if you're at the restaurant you
don't just really walk up and get away
of course you're gonna spend that
quality time as well
starting Spotify
when I heard the Spotify story I
I really wanted to meet you because
I consider myself to be ambitious but
there are some challenges that I would
just view as impossible
and at the time when
you consider how the music industry was
that it's ran by these big record labels
predominantly and they own the music
to be a young kid from Sweden
and believe that you could change that
for me is a special type of delusion
like it's like yeah it's just an
impossible task it's what I just would
have thought okay some things are the
way they are they're immovable objects
that is one of them yeah why didn't you
think that was a impossible task
um
well I I think for several reasons but I
think that is the beautiful narrative
team of an entrepreneur as well right
we move mountains I'm sure Elon was you
know even more insurmountable thing
electric cars and it hadn't been a
successful car companies for uh I think
a century or something
um or at least you know many many
decades in the US and he managed to do
that so I think it's it's part illusion
uh dilution sorry
um but but the other part I think
um also is that what I realized is
for even committing to this idea so the
the why not part
I probably spent 500 hours
learning about this problem
and the scarcest resource we have in the
world today by far is time
and when you have high quality people
that spend thousands of hours on a
problem you find new Solutions
and so the biggest thing for Humanity I
believe is simply that I believe we're
capable of doing practically anything
but
there aren't that many people that can
see these multi-dimensional things with
that right experience that happens to me
at that right time they're spending
thousands of hours of trying to needle
in a haystack see that opportunity
through that very very tiny prism
and and
um
um even today when I think about it some
of my other businesses it kind of worked
the same way so I started a healthcare
business about five years ago but I was
spending
um
I think the first interview when I
mentioned it was in 2009
um and I started the company five years
ago uh 2018 so I I probably spent a
decade thinking about this problem
um and I couldn't figure out a solution
2008. yeah yeah
you started the company in 2008 no no I
started the company the Healthcare
company in 2018 18. but I started
thinking about it 2008. oh okay
um so I have a notebook with all my
crazy ideas most of them amount to
nothing uh quite often someone else
comes along and does them and I'm happy
and it's amazing
um but every now and then nothing
happens for a great period of time and I
kind of feel that itch to maybe make a
difference myself and I and I say that
because like the realization there was
um
I'd spend up until that point thousands
of hours understanding the Healthcare
System why it is for the way it is the
incentive schemes and the what the NHS
is doing and what someone else is doing
and the Public Health Care System
Insurance business direct to Consumer
things the the longevity curves of human
beings the disease groups the costs
curves like all of those aspects um
about it similar to how you're
describing looking at Rockets
um but you know imagine you're spending
a thousand hours a rocket not just kind
of casually researching it I am sure you
will find novel ways of how to attack
the problem it may not be because you
know if you're not a physicist you may
not come up with the next rocket engine
but you may find another twist uh too on
how to attack this problem
and I don't really think it comes down
to that and so uh in the space of music
I don't know anything about the music
industry going into it
um but I would argue a few years into it
I was probably one of the most foremost
experts on copyright in the world around
like the dmca and um what the U.S
copyright regime looked like and what
what um other regimes look like and how
um you know performance rights societies
label rights and what color rights
mechanical rights performing rights uh
all of those different aspects the all
the different code is RC numbers ISBN
numbers and how they related and so on
and so forth and and um
um you know I find like people either
get too modeled in on the details and
don't see the bigger picture or they
stay two top level pictures to really
see the new ones and the question is how
do you dive deep enough where you see it
and figure out which problems to solve
in what order
um and and I was at that point
by probably 2007 having spent a year on
Spotify but the team was super small so
it really wasn't a big commits at that
time and I wasn't sure at that time but
then I realized that hey this is
actually possible because we'd built the
product that showcased the technology of
what we're doing and it felt like if you
had all the worst music on your hard
drive
so then the real problem ended up being
can we get the music industry to accept
this and to that I had no idea but I
felt like this is so obviously if this
came out in the marketplace what
consumers would ask for now the only
question is is the music industry going
to allow this and that took me another
year and a half 18 months to learn the
answer and it was completely binary we
almost died probably four times in that
process and ran out of money and a
record company saying no no this is
never gonna happen until eventually one
day the Stars aligned and we were able
to launch but that was not a given but
it felt like the right bet to make
because
you know it was a binary outcome either
we'd fail the price wasn't all too bad
if we would succeed it was clearly so
that at least this would resonate very
well with consumers
was there any moments where you thought
that it wasn't going to happen I.E
conversations you had with record labels
where someone very high up says
absolutely no way I met many times uh I
would say
um probably once every month or two over
a two year period I thought that this
probably won't pan out uh and it was
incredibly demoralizing I I usually joke
but like in the beginning of that
process I had hair and then in the end
of it I lost all of the hair I probably
gained 30 pounds in weight during that
period of time
um
it was awful
um but through it all my co-founder
Martin uh probably a factor of just who
he is as an individual but also probably
because he didn't participate in these
meetings uh kept being really upbeat
kept being
um you know amazing support and so don't
worry about it you're gonna figure it
out and you just kept believing in me
and then he also said a few times you
know when that wasn't enough he said
don't worry about it we'll figure out
something else if this doesn't work out
it felt to me like I always had a safety
net and it was just the amount the push
that I needed to do this
um and again talking about not giving
advice but to the advice that I do give
to other people is to share the burden
with someone it is so important and I
know I get most of the credits
for Spotify but it is really a team
effort uh from the gustavs and Alex and
all those people but then also in the
early days from uh Martin in believing
in me uh and and knowing uh or this kind
of Supernatural ability that I'm gonna
pull it off somehow
I must have told you a story which I
guess has stayed with you about
perseverance and the power of
perseverance the double-edged sword to
that is
sometimes it's right to quit as well
yeah and knowing when to persevere and
knowing when you're just wasting your
time which is as you said the most
important currency of all yeah you know
that's where you know art meets science
um there is no scientific answer because
it depends it's an art to know uh when
something is futile and when something
is worth doing but I call it that sort
of binary outcome but uh with uneven
distribution right so if you think about
it as a curve
even if it's 50 50 whether you succeed
but on the upside you can win a lot more
than you can lose and all you can really
lose is one time but the upside maybe a
hundred
it's probably worth
uh persuading obviously it's that's the
science part the art thing is okay well
is it really hundred times is it 10
times and and have I already lost but
I'm just not aware of it
um that's the art and also in that I
hear an optimism bias from two
co-founders
the the constant now we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
how important do you think that is
especially you know you hire a lot of
people is that something you're like
looking for in the people that you work
with that bias towards will figure it
out
um I think again it depends on the road
you're hiring for you need a team uh I
think it's really important that you
just don't surround yourself with just
yes people or optimists you need the
naysayer in the room as well you need
the people who will balance it out and
be the one who says um I'm not sure this
is going to work out
um and and so often I think that's the
that's the important part we keep
talking about it over the CFO or sales
people but again you can have a deal
making CFO and uh salesperson that's
happy go lucky it may not be a great
combo you may want the the CFO to be
skeptical about the sales Pipeline and a
happy-go-lucky salesperson or the
inverse maybe a like really diligent
that and a CFO that maybe sort of like
don't worry about it we will sort it out
um but I but I think so much about that
is the subtleties we have we don't have
a perfect model of the world
um and uh the more experience I have
it's the cheesy thing to say but the
less I realized that I actually know and
so much of this are actually down in the
nuances and most people are
um above the nuances don't really
understand the issues well enough or too
bogged down in the details to understand
the bigger picture and and going that
sort of up and down that's sort of super
detail-oriented but also being able to
go up and see the big pictures that is
um and simplifying very complex Concepts
I think some of the most amazing
entrepreneurs in the world are experts
at and that is the superpower
and that is certainly one that I'm
trying to hone
um and work on but when you see it like
Steve Jobs when you take very complex
things and people say he didn't
understand engineering and Technical
problems it's not true yes he may not
have been an engineer he may not have
known how to write code but he certainly
could empathize with what um made an
amazing engineer tick empathize with
different Technical Solutions will have
different inputs and outputs and he
understood it and
um he was brilliant in taking very
complex ideas and understanding how to
make that resonate for the everyday
person
these Tales I hear of you sort of being
outside record labels and waiting for
the CEO to come out so that you could
catch them or trying to cost I don't
know the assistant outside and asking
when the CEOs was coming outside so that
you could get a meeting with them yeah
are these Tales true
um as with many they're probably
exaggerated a little bit um where's the
truth uh well the the truth is that
certainly happened but it wasn't you
know I've heard uh people recounted us
that I slept outside of the the record
labels kind of in a sleeping bag that
that didn't happen uh that happened
another time in my career but it wasn't
um it didn't happen there but but it
certainly happened that I'd book A Week
a flight to New York with no meeting
booked uh with basically an open
calendar and about 20 phone calls a day
just trying to figure out a time to get
on this the schedule of a senior VP or a
CEO Etc
that certainly happened and that taught
me another thing too which is that these
assistants like you better befriend them
because they are the keys to the kingdom
um and most people don't care about them
at all uh but they're very influential
they're very powerful
um and uh and and you know uh that was
hard in the beginning but then I
realized that
um they got to see me as an individual I
saw them as an individual and eventually
you know the this this is not uh we tend
to believe the world is more logical
than what it is but a lot of it is based
on relationships So eventually some of
them started taking a liking to me and
so when there was the opportunity and
they could prioritize 10 other things
for that CEO to do but I was there I was
friendly uh and easy to work with show
up with no moments notice even if you
know it was 20 minutes before finding
out about it I would show up
um and so I was I was easy to deal with
so take away all that complexity in
order to achieve the out outcome that I
wanted to do and sometimes that is as
simple as it is just be consistent be
the easiest person to deal with and
you'd be surprised how many problems it
solves
did you invest your personal Capital
into starting Spotify because I I read
again that you'd spend pretty much all
of your personal wealth to start the
company yeah yeah I did uh so invested
not all of it but quite substantial
amounts of it uh and my co-founder
invested even more but he obviously had
a much larger sum of money
um from the beginning
um yeah so all in all I think we
invested about 10 million dollars uh
into this
um by ourselves which was also crazy
because you know back then today 10
million into a startup just was it isn't
a big number many startups that have
done that before but doing that on a
seed stage uh back in 2007 uh that just
was unheard of it was usually 500k seed
check sums Etc what if it hadn't worked
out what would have been the personal
implications for you financially uh the
personal implications that I went from
not having to have a job to then
probably having to go back to having a
job so I basically took that security
that I built up that 22 I'm set for life
and I gave that up
um in a moment's notice
um and
um
yeah I mean
um I I don't know what to say I think
from a purely logical point of view it
was probably a terrible decision but
betting on myself and betting on
yourself would probably be again uh I
say I should give advice but it is
probably the the best advice I could
give many people is is you know because
especially those that want to invest in
various startups Etc
but they may not have a lot of money and
then I will say well why don't you just
bet on yourself instead why don't you
just try to like work for one of these
startups like you said and and maybe
take a little bit more equity and a
little bit less pay and take out of your
cash instead because that way you
increase the likelihood hopefully if you
know you're good of the company being a
success and it just feels like the more
prudent thing to do and so I had a
sneaky feeling that that was the right
thing to do but investing as much
probably wasn't the smartest thing to do
a new podcast sponsor that I'm super
excited to talk about with all of you is
LinkedIn jobs hiring as I would know is
one of the most important steps in your
business without good people there is no
company trust me I found out along the
way that your business is nothing
without good people you want to be a
hundred percent certain though that you
have access to the best candidates
available and that's why you have to
check out LinkedIn jobs LinkedIn jobs
helps you to find the right people for
your team faster and for free so when
I'm expanding my team LinkedIn is my
first Port of Call I'd highly recommend
it on LinkedIn jobs posting a job is
super easy and you can add a purple
hashtag hiring frame around your
LinkedIn profile to spread the word
LinkedIn jobs helps you find the
qualified candidates you want to talk to
faster post your job for free at
linkedin.com
doac that's linkedin.com doac to post
your job for free terms and conditions
apply as you may know this podcast is
sponsored by if you're living under a
rock you might have missed that I've
come to learn over time not all of the
products they have are for me but the
ones that are for me have really really
changed my life in a profound way all of
the products are designed for different
use cases and different people for me as
you'll probably know the ready to drink
bottles are a staple of my life at the
moment and they have been for many many
years but for a lot of other people they
have the hot and savory which is a five
minute hot meal that's nutritionally
complete it contains all the good stuff
that all your products contain which is
the 23 vitamins and minerals and the
wonderful balance of sort of nutritional
completeness and then you have the bars
as well if you've heard about fuel on
this podcast you've heard me talking
about it a lot you're aware that I'm an
investor in the company you're aware
that I'm on the board of the company
and you're not sure where to start I
would highly recommend starting with the
bestseller bundle basically we'll send
you a package in the post containing all
of the favorite products that people
love and then you try them all and stick
with the ones that really really fit you
the link is in the description below to
try the best seller bundle
Spotify
goes on to be I mean success is probably
an understatement I know the journey to
that success had multiple near-death
experiences to get there one of the key
things key moments I reflect on as a
Spotify customer
um is when Apple launched their
competing product Apple music in 2015 I
believe it was and there was lots of
Articles saying that this would be the
death of Spotify yeah I think I was even
concerned as a very loyal Spotify user
yeah I thought [__] you know they have
all the phones yeah they have they're
kind of like the mafia they could just
squash you yeah most companies when
Apple comes into their territory
shaking their boots yeah what was it
like in your office that day when Apple
music launched a competing product you
know when you live in the thick of the
fire you're not concerned about the
things that everyone else is concerned
about I usually say public perception
lacks about six to 12 months what's
actually going on and and so in our case
we'd known that Apple's going to launch
something for probably the better part
of a year
because they have the Beats acquisition
beforehand and we were hearing all sorts
of rumors Etc about what it was so
absolutely you have to be worried when
one of the greatest companies on Earth
decides to compete with you so we were
concerned about it
um uh and we were kind of doubling down
on what our positioning was going to be
so you kind of like double and triple
checked whether or not um you know you
were deluding yourself into believing
things to be true and and so for
instance in our case one of the big
things we had a some strategic pillars
that we were focusing on one of them we
call ubiquity because we always knew
this would eventually be the case we we
thought that consumers would value the
ability to work across all devices and
all ecosystem and our bet would be that
um
any competitor we might have had would
actually focus on reinforcing their own
ecosystem and not care about all the
other stuff so the primary reason they
were into a music service would be to
make their own devices better not to
make the world's best music service
and um and so you know that's why we
made such an effort of integrating into
cars integrating into all sorts of weird
devices smart fridges whatever you might
think um and so so it was kind of like
reiterating that but I felt pretty good
about that position
um and going back
and then there's always this sort of
like what if they figured out something
that we just wouldn't have thought about
uh and I remember we were constantly
talking to the product teams about this
uh and like what what if they come up
with this and we're literally trying
this every game theorizing every
possible angle
um on it
um but I think at the end of the day we
we kind of went through the Thousand
scenarios kind of thing we knew we'd
prepared as well as we could
um we
um anticipated a certain type of product
there was this kind of one percent or
ten percent chance whatever you want to
Quantified as where it would just be
wrong and they'd come up with something
that widely superseded any of our
expectations but that very day
remember we'd been preparing for that
day for so long so the first reaction
was kind of them announcing it which we
expected them to do uh and then seeing
the walkthrough of the product and
realizing that okay well we prepared for
this we thought about this Etc and so
weirdly enough as the rest of the world
kind of like gasped for air
um we were thinking about it okay well
this was what we expected
um and back to that point distribution
was the amazing thing they hadn't come
up with something on the product side
that we just didn't anticipate but it
was really just about distribution and
there was nothing we could do to guard
ourselves against it but we felt like we
had a superior experience
um on the personalization side the fact
that you know if you have a Windows
machine and an iPhone
um Spotify would work but Apple music
um wouldn't at that time so there were
many of those things that we um I
thought had a better positioning than
they had I've long thought that I've
tried both I mean I've tried it when it
came out and I couldn't stick to it um
and I think me and my friends who are in
my music group we all concluded that the
personalization how Spotify understands
me yeah is really the thing it's hard to
know why you do what you do as a
consumer yeah but from analyzing it a
bit more deeply um it just felt like I'd
built there was a lot of investment I'd
done to my playlists and all those
things but Spotify just knew me better
it seems to have much more data than
um data on me and understands me and is
more of a bespoke solution to me than
Apple was and also the user experience
is not great and I just can't get past
that I just so I tried it and I bounced
I I just stuck with Spotify
um
Apple uh I use the word Matthew earlier
on a lot of people don't know this but
they take 30 revenues on pretty much
every new app in the store yeah they've
rejected your audio book app multiple
times
um there's a rumor going around that
they even delay how quickly you can
release new updates of your app and
delay how that reaches phones what's
your opinion on Apple and what they do
and how they conduct themselves well
um it's
um as a consumer uh let's start off with
apple is a fantastic company and they
make amazing products I really do
believe that
um I've been a Mac User since
I can't even remember probably late 90s
when I could first afford one
uh all the way to now and obviously use
the iPhone and Apple watches and all
that stuff so let's start with that and
I think that's hard to square then that
there's this other company that's
fiercely
um focused on just
um
itself and constantly trying to do
things by itself and not working well
with others
um and
um
those are perhaps two different sides of
the same coin but
um you know the the way that manifests
itself
um I think that it's a company in many
cases that still sees itself as an
underdog but don't realize that they
become Goliath and so many of the
tactics that made it the rebel kind of
thing are now stifling Innovation and
it's really hurting consumers it's a
great extent with the 30 you talked
about with the fact that you know
Spotify can't
um or any developer if you don't pay the
30 you can't even speak to your
consumers it is kind of absurd
um so you know there there's a
ruthlessness
um on the business side of Apple
um and and perhaps it's always been so I
don't know I never got the opportunity
to meet Steve Jobs but
um
where just from an ethos point of view
it's just not me
um and um
um I have a hard time squaring that with
me as the consumer and me as the
business leader
um and needless to say I I do believe
that apple
can and should play fair and I think it
would be way better for the world if
they did
um and I think
um that it would actually help them in
many regards to switch their tactics and
realize that they are the Goliath at
this point they're not David
um and so yeah
one of the things I want to close on um
is your philosophy so I guess it's the
same answer because spotify's philosophy
towards what's made it successful will
probably be in many respects a
reflection of your philosophies towards
business and and
um more broadly towards life but when I
sit here and I think a lot of people
will sit here and say
um
there's clearly something unique about
you about the way you approach problem
solving problems life business all of
those things that has been
that has defined you and set you apart
are you aware of what that is what those
principles are
um no I don't think so but I think
you're right in that
um you know the the way I would describe
Spotify
um to people you're right that it is
scary sometimes watching Spotify uh
trying to watch it from a distance and
not just be in it because sometimes it's
doing things where I'm like
how did how did people know that we were
supposed to do it this way
um and it would be how I would approach
solving a problem and it's kind of how
um you know we've internalized certain
things but the best way is it's 17 years
old now and it is a teenager that's
liberating itself so it's not 100 me uh
in fact it is this much broader uh
different being uh there are aspects of
it that
um hasn't taken after me at all in um
product development you know Gustav is a
formidable product leader as an example
and Alex is a formidable business leader
and the two of them are now leading more
of the day today and they're certainly
instilling their personal uh values and
their personal uh perspective of the of
the company too which I think they're
totally entitled to doing having been
with the company for 12 plus years both
of them
um but it is interesting seeing it
because we're approaching things now in
a way I wouldn't always do it's not
inconsistent with important principles
of mine but but it's certainly not
directed and the other part is I started
this as a 23 year old and the 23 year
old Daniel while many parts are the same
uh the 40 year old Daniel with two kids
having seen that have changed
perspectives as well I have a different
feeling about work and and the
importance of that in my life still very
important but may not be the sole most
important thing that I do so just to
mention one and so it has similarities
uh but there's differences to me as an
individual too but I think if you
compare me to 23 year old Daniel the 30
year old Daniel's a 40 year old Daniel
um I've evolved to and and candidly I'm
in that period at the moment where I'm
perhaps trying to figure out who the 40
year old Daniel really is because it's a
different one than the 30 year old one
um maybe it's subtleties
but um I think in quite a big way also
and just thinking about something like a
culture the 23 year old Daniel
culture was having a ping pong table uh
30 year old Daniel would have said yeah
culture is important but didn't really
understand why and the 40 year old
Daniel would be
um you know the 30 year old Daniel would
be more strategy than culture actually
and the 40 year old Daniel is all about
culture almost to the point where
strategy is
um secondary if not even tertiary to
that
um and what he wrote Daniel's all about
culture yeah way more so what is the
culture well and that's the amazing
thing because it is the most scalable
thing done right of a company and it's
the hardest thing right because it is
everything and nothing it is every
positive action that's happening in the
companies every negative action or
company every person that's joining
every person is leaving is impacting
culture
and so
um in its Essence I believe culture is
about rewarding the positive behaviors
who want to see in the company and
obviously dissuade the negative for the
positive behaviors you want to see well
one of them is taking risks
um and failing and how do you do that
when you have eight or nine thousand
people inside of a company responsibly
how do you when the common status quo is
we don't like failure you don't get
promoted based on failure you get
promoted based on being successful any
Duke has this thinking in bets she talks
about I love that is thinking about
poker ships on the table and and she
said one time when when we spoke she
said to me it's like a company is like
um
everyone has chips at the table we just
don't know how many we have and so the
people that have been successful have
way more so they have leniency and
allowancy in the culture of any
organizations to do more than someone
who just started
um and perhaps have a less lesser ones
and if you failed enough times what's
naturally going to happen is that you
won't have the same agency in a large
organization they impact things too so
then the the Counterpoint to that would
be well how do you then
create an environment where people
um are allowed to take risks and then
balance that with say a Spotify at this
point where we have a huge amount of
responsibility too we have tens of
millions of creators that have their
livelihood of them platform so we can
just experiment with how we're paying
out and so on and so forth right and the
550 million consumers we have to be
responsible with their data we can't you
know put new things in front of them
without testing them and so on and so
forth and so
um there's this constant tension between
being Innovative taking risks
um and um you know at the same time
obviously being responsible and and
that's hard
but that's all about culture
I'm absolutely obsessed with the subject
of culture because I really think it's
an under underappreciated factor in
um and why businesses are the way they
are I think you could basically take
a person off the street and the culture
you drop them in determines the behavior
you'll get from them yeah and so
um and having sat here and interviewed
like Sir Alex Ferguson's ex-team mates
yeah you just come to learn that sir
Alex Ferguson's greatness wasn't a
strategy right they all say to me I
remember Patrice and ever said to me
that he walked in on a we were playing
Arsenal yeah on a Sunday in London yeah
and he walked in and just said Lads
listen beautiful weather outside don't
[__] up my Sunday and walked out because
his thing was about management he just
had this culture the other thing they
said to me which is always stayed with
me is Rio Ferdinand said to me how many
times do you think he came into the
training ground dressing room yeah in 26
years like I don't know they said twice
really they need to come in there the
culture was in there yeah
and it was self-policing when it's
strong right yeah but you're right
sports teams the ones that do really
well uh I was being told an Arsenal
story that I probably can't share but uh
you could see bits and pieces of
mikhail's
um you know how he's pushing that team
culture at the moment too which seems
very fascinating uh with some of the
almost Antics uh it seems to be doing
this All or Nothing season that was I
think last season
um as well
um so you can see that and I love
studying that with sports teams because
you know it's 11 placed on the pitch how
do you make these people gel together
um and form a team
um hugely important thing so I agree but
but also like imagine if you had 11 new
players uh um you know yeah can you even
form or Chelsea these days yeah right
um can you even uh create a culture that
way uh or is it something that should be
done intentional
um I mean if you're growing a company
you're growing the number of employees
by 50 two years in a row most of your
employees probably won't have been here
even for a year it will change things
whereas if you make something where it's
more of a gradual change it will uh it's
easier I'm not saying it's trivial but
to to kind of have the same culture and
I think many Founders make that mistake
when they overhide they don't understand
the implication of the culture they just
look at sort of more Warm Bodies
but it's all these other subtle things
that starts breaking
Daniel we've got a closing tradition on
this podcast where the last guest leaves
a question for the next guest and I love
this question because
um you don't like giving advice so yeah
this is a perfect one for you
um
what is the advice
that someone could have but didn't give
you at 21 years old that would have made
you more successful at the thing you now
do
I
um
I think uh we we spoke about it I've
gone through iterations of uh trying to
learn from other people a model that a
huge part of that has been kind of
um
optimizing for my strengths and not
covering my weaknesses and I wish that I
um
realized much earlier on that perhaps my
superpower is that I'm pretty good all
around her and not particularly good at
anything so I used to think for instance
that I had this brilliant you know I
modeled myself on the mark zuckerbergs
of the world of like I need to run every
product meeting I need to be the best
product person in the world
it just wasn't me and it took me a while
to realize that and be comfortable
um saying that right
um but
um
I I have realized that I do like a lot
of different things I love learning
about new things and perhaps that is my
superpower uh to realize that the person
who's doing PR that's quite an
interesting thing to learn about there
are interesting things about employment
law how that came to be and trying to
understand that and you the list goes on
and on and on and I love that
um and I wish I would have probably
understood that earlier about myself
because that would have allowed myself
to not model so much on other people but
but somehow be more introspective and
listen to myself
and I think that's really one of the
things I I take away from you said very
eloquently is that your proof that
entrepreneurs can Buck a number of
different Trends you know and still be
wildly successful and that evidence
means to someone like me that there's no
such thing as a entrepreneur in terms of
how they operate what they're interested
in
um and that there's many ways to be a
successful entrepreneur and it really
from what you've just said there the
most sure-fire way of becoming a
successful entrepreneur is actually
looking inward versus looking outwards
at like oh how does Elon do it or how
does Daniel do it yeah
um which stays with me a lot because
it's really changed my thinking on a few
really important things that I think
I've been
yeah I've been limit I've been limiting
myself on
um Daniel thank you so much thank you so
much for having me thank you building
such a great business and building a
business that that is
um I guess it even though you're number
one still embodies the kind of first
principle Underdog mentality there's
something about Spotify which is it
feels I know people don't like this word
but I don't know if you do but it feels
more like a family because I've met a
lot of the people there I know a lot of
them yeah and they're like really nice
people that are very open books it
doesn't feel like a big corporate to me
yeah um it's very humble in its in its
approach but it's also very ambitious
yeah and it strikes that balance really
wonderful wonderfully well and it's some
it's a company in a brand that I deeply
resonate with for that reason it's a
wonderful wonderful thing and I think
um you know you talked about wanting to
do work that brings good to the world
the good to the world that Spotify has
done in my view is in quantifiable
because I mean music is a is a wonderful
thing but what you're doing now in
podcasting as well and how you've really
owned and driven that industry forward
for people like me to have these longer
form more contextual conversations I
think it's hard to measure the good
that's done to the world but it's
certainly thank you an important one
thank you that means a lot to me and
you're right
um you know it's about being humble
while doing it but um you know ambition
and humbleness may not seem like they go
hand in hand and so I think you capture
the essence of what we like Spotify to
be at its best which is super ambitious
but yet humble uh with all of its past
success all of that stuff that we're
still learning super curious I I never
told the story before but when I went I
went on a trip to Sweden and I was there
with some of your colleagues so Gustav
who's head of product right and Alex
who's head of this business everything
that makes money yep and I was there
with Shaquille as well who's a good
friend and colleague of yours and has
been for a long time and they sat me
down at a table for for about 30 minutes
or an hour yeah and said
you're a podcaster Steve yeah tell us
everything we need to know about
podcasting yep how can we make um
Spotify better for you as a podcaster
and for the very people at the top of
Spotify to sit and listen so intently
to me and then to act upon what I said
and then give me feedback weeks later
and say okay we're now you know working
on this having listened to you it's not
something that a big corporate that was
arrogant or very sure of themselves or
lost that mentality would ever do that
stayed with me because it's hard to do
that when you get big to really be
curious and humble and that's exactly
what Spotify is so I wish I wish you all
the luck in the world and I'm sure you
don't need it because you've got a
wonderful culture of um people and great
people around you but just wanted to say
thank you for that well no thank you and
I mean again yes we listen but it's also
because you are innovating on your side
and uh uh with all the aspects even
seeing your studio here today it's kind
of like bringing it to the next level so
that's that's amazing to see that you're
able to do that amazing to bring these
conversations to the world and we all
get the benefit to learn from them as
well without maybe having the
opportunity like you have to meet all
these individuals too and that's going
to bring a lot of growth Journeys uh for
a lot of people too
so thank you
[Music]
we've got an exciting new sponsor on
this podcast and I couldn't be more
excited to announce that we're now
working with Shopify and if there's one
tool that I use pretty much every single
day of my businesses that is certainly
Shopify I'm sure you've all heard about
Shopify but for some reason if you
haven't then Shopify is the Commerce
platform that is revolutionizing
millions of businesses worldwide whether
you're starting a side hustle a new
project with a friend or a global
business Shopify has you covered you
guys may know that we recently sold a
product on this platform called the DAR
overseer conversation cards which
featured questions from the guests in
these episodes and from start to finish
from launching that product we used
Shopify a total Game Changer makes life
incredibly incredibly smooth when it
relates to business and a tool that my
team have absolutely loved using which
is not always the case with technology
we couldn't have launched those
conversation cards without it and if you
guys haven't tried Shopify out for
yourself then I highly suggest you do
head to shopify.com Bartlett to take
your business to the next level today
and let me know how you get on that
shopify.com Butler let me know how you
get on
[Music]
foreign